et cet autre rassemblement en place de
barcelone contre le passé ni terre sur
appel et en présence du leader politique
florian philippot les détails tout de
suite notre reporter cyrielle benavides
bull mouillant
le cortège a terminé son parcours sur la
place pierre laroque dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris à proximité du
ministère de la santé au lieu d'arriver
habituel pour les patriotes qui chaque
samedi manifestent contre le passé les
restrictions dans les sanitaires nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de certains
manifestants pour savoir si les
revendications étaient toujours les
mêmes ou si d'autres s'ils étaient
ajoutés notamment depuis le conseil de
défense de ce lundi 6 décembre je vous
propose d'écouter la réponse l'union
européenne a demandé veut mettre la
vaccination obligatoire le pass
sanitaire qui restreint les libertés des
gens on peut plus aller dans les cafés
dans les restaurants les ici côte est
qui sont fermés c'est lamentable et on
nous parle maintenant de troisième dose
à quand va s'arrêter de cette arnaque
quatrième go 5e 12 quand est ce que les
gens vont se réveiller en fait ce qui me
choque le plus c'est les injonctions
liberticide pour un vaccin qui - il
marche plus on veut nous l'imposer donc
j'espère que les gens se rendent compte
que ce n'est pas le but de sauver des
vies qui est en train de se jouer c'est
le but de contrôler des gi je ne me
ferai pas vacciner et ben j'irai pas au
cinéma j'irai pas au resto je m'en fous
je m'en fout éperdument
ils vont pas venir s'ils veulent
maintenant prison moi je suis volontaire
j'y vais il n'y a pas de souci on va
faire éclater leur le système de
l'intérieur c'est en musique et drapeaux
tricolores il sait que la manifestation
s'est déroulé pour florian philippot les
français sont toujours aussi motivés au
fil des semaines on voit des gens karine
qui était vacciné qui veulent pas la
troisième dose que pas de la 4e et la
suite - les parents qui dépend de leurs
gamins et on voit les melons qui sont
extrêmement motivés et on pense on est
persuadé que le rapport de pensent ils
en train de basculer complètement
les gens ils en ont ras-le-bol tous les
mensonges de berens et de l'autre ils
veulent leur liberté volant vie normale
et veulent qu'on tourne la page cette
folie ce n'est pas en se soumettant
qu'on retrouve la liberté ça c'est faux
ça ne marche pas comme ça dans le colis
10 mhz c'est en résistant qu'on retrouve
sa liberté une manifestation nommée
défilé pour la liberté qui se
renouvellent maintenant tous les samedis
depuis cet été à la fin de chacune
d'elles des prises de parole ont lieu et
pour clore la journée celle de florian
philippot candidat à la présidentielle